un choix posés pendant le confinement si
la question de la fusion est apparu dès
le 15 mars
la crise sanitaire a permis aux deux
listes de se rapprocher arrivé en tête
avec 42 % des voix françois morton
intègre 8 membres de la liste d'olivier
paréja ça fait des décennies que les
équipes de guyancourt pour tous et et
les sensibilités écologistes travaillent
ensemble et donc nous nous sommes
retrouvés tout à fait naturellement
en s'apercevant mais ce n'était pas
vraiment une surprise que nos programmes
sont très convergent et que nous avions
déjà de toute façon travaillé ensemble
durant ce mandat issu de la liste
majoritaire lors des élections
municipales de 2014 olivier parent et
j'avais quitté le groupe en cours de
mandat il a choisi sur ce scrutin de
créer sa propre liste le 15 mars dernier
il était crédité de 16% des suffrages
dans les idées qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé pendant la campagne il y avait
la démocratie participative et donc on
avait mis en avant les groupes actions
projets qui sont des des regroupements
des habitants des services de la ville
des associations des élus autour d'un
projet pour élaborer même le projet et
c'est cette façon de fonctionner assez
innovante c'est quelque chose qui nous
tenait vraiment à coeur des volontés de
fusion partagé par grégory pape le
candidat de nouvel élan à guyancourt
souhaité créer une seule liste d'union
locale le 28 juin prochain les
guyancourt toi devront donc faire le
choix entre la liste du maire sortant
françois morton celle de grégory pape
est ensemble agissons pour guyancourt
mené par rodolphe baril